welcome Kareem abdul-jabbar how are you
sir
I'm doing Grover thanks for having me
you bet absolutely also I should
introduce you as author I have the book
right here your latest tome Sherlock and
Mycroft Mycroft and Sherlock Mycroft and
oh my gosh Mycroft and Sherlock I
transposed them incorrectly Mycroft and
Sherlock this is what number book is
this of yours on the or Jesus about 14
or 15 but that's the second one in this
series well it's gonna be three mmm this
is this book - okay and we'll discuss
that a little bit as well as your Kareem
abdul-jabbar collection there's an
auction that's gonna be going on so
there's lots to talk about with you but
the first thing I want to hit you is you
just sat down you saw my Michigan
Wolverine helmet there's on the desk you
asked me if I was a Michigan guy and
then proceeded to tell me that coming
out of high school you were also
recruited by Michigan yeah I was
recruited by Michigan I went to see a
coach track Cassie that was Cassie
senior year they lost to the Bruins in
in the finals that year uh-huh so I
visited both Michigan and UCLA and it
was no contest of course you know I
visited Michigan it was March it was
freezing I visited oh I know but you
know two weeks later I came out to LA
from my trip out there's no contest
the weather was essentially what oh my
goodness the weather in the campus and
the coeds and everything you know just
too much it was work it all worked is
what you're saying what did John
wouldn't say to you do you recall what
he said to you but I know I got out we
came out on a Friday um went over to
coach Wooden's office on on Saturday
morning and we didn't even talk about
basketball we talked about academics he
said he thought I'd do well and
academically and that that's what he
hoped for and we went to lunch he went
to lunch yeah so what did Michigan do
did day Wine and Dine you in any way
shape but Norman spent the weekend there
great school beautiful campus in every
danger and coach crack was was wonderful
Cassie was incredible but you know I I
just figured candy show you around yeah
he showed me around because he took me
to the movie
do you remember which movie Cassie can't
remember but it was the the movie
theater closest to campus cuz he had a
lifetime pass
that's the Michigan theatre yes I guess
Lew Alcindor where you could I was yeah
okay
and then interesting you have a new
national live stage show coming out
called becoming Kareem yeah what is that
what is that about well it's it's a live
show and I basically I'm interviewed and
I talk about my life the things that for
me I the book that I just did becoming
Kareem is for younger readers and I
talked about the mentors I had and the
people that helped me make some good
choices that I made in my life so I
talked about that and you know what that
process was all about and how did you
become Kareem like the name Kareem
abdul-jabbar how did you well uh the
whole idea about your name is it should
inspire you to good things so my name
means noble or generous and hopefully
I'm inspired to be noble and generous in
living my life and that that's that's
what it's all about Kareem abdul-jabbar
here on the Rich Eisen show okay
LeBron's gonna make his Los Angeles
debut on the road on Thursday and then
obviously here in Los Angeles
on Saturday how do you think he will
fare here in LA Kareem abdul-jabbar
LeBron has already done very well here
in LA because the the people appreciate
you know what he's all about you know in
terms of his his Civic consciousness and
they know he's the best player on the
planet so you know all the fans are so
excited that I I was mentioning earlier
I can't go anywhere without excited fans
coming up to me and saying how far we're
gonna go in the playoffs and you know
the the excitement and interest is there
and it all has to do with LeBron coming
to town now you I'm sure you've heard
the question of legacy in him coming to
a spot where there are already so many
banners yours a dozen banners hanging
inside of staples right now does he need
to win here H
championship to be considered a Laker in
that regard
Kareem oh well I'm sure that that's what
he's hoping for and that's what
management is hoping for and he still
has the skill and leadership qualities
to make that happen so you know they
they didn't get LeBron when you know
he's his clock is ticking
real loud and he's not gonna be around
for for a long time he has another
couple of good years to give this
franchise and hopefully to show them the
leadership skills that they need to make
it all the way to the top no I know I
just didn't think the question of being
is you are obviously on the pantheon of
Laker dumb and many people think he has
the opportunity to do that here but he
has to win a championship to do that
would you agree with that assessment
well maybe that would figure in the
decision of whether or not this was a
successful transition mhm but LeBron
does and everything to prove mm-hmm you
know so in that sense I don't think he
can screw up because you know he has
nothing to prove he's bringing
considerable skills and leadership
qualities to this team the Lakers will
definitely benefit from that Kareem
abdul-jabbar here on the Rich Eisen show
studio and again I want we'll talk about
your book and your collection in a
second I want to talk colin kaepernick
with you a little bit here sure
have you spoken with yes I have spoken
with home was the last time you spoke to
Colin a couple months ago okay yeah what
was may I pry into finding out when your
conversation with him was about I just
asked him what he was doing and it was
before the Nike commercial came out okay
so he was kind of secretive but he said
you know that he had plans and the fact
that the ownership seemed to collude
against him having a job in the NFL that
that wasn't going to stop him from doing
what he wanted to do with his life and
do you feel that those there are some
who say that Colin Kaepernick
will one day be viewed as one of the
more important civil rights figures in
sports or this country would you agree
with that assessment Kareem I I would
absolutely agree with
what he did was important because he
showed a new generation of of youth that
it's okay to have an opinion and it's
okay to state in as long as you do it
with some intelligence in class you have
to say what what's on your mind so Colin
used his platform as a professional
athlete to bring attention to a very bad
problem in our country too many black
Americans get killed by the police for
no good reason and this is a real issue
this is not something that has been
contrived Colin is not trying to diss
disrespect our country or our military
he wants our country to live up to what
the Constitution says it's about you
know equal protection under the law and
that hasn't happened and tragically for
black Americans it it ends up with too
many black Americans did well it seems
that Jim Brown who you have obviously a
history being at the forefront of these
issues with way back in the day thinks
that Colin and others should not be
kneeling during the national anthem to
make this point where do you stand on
that subject well you know I think
that's a matter of opinion
Colin used the attention that he got to
make a very serious statement so it
wasn't completely a failure he got
people's attention and they understand
what he was talking about so much so
that they tried to change the subject
so Colin knew what he was doing and you
know I I don't feel that he screwed up
it at all he he had to take the chance
that they would come down on him like
that but as far as he's concerned it was
worth it do you speak to Jim Brown at
all I haven't spoken to Jim Brown in a
couple of months but I do speak to him
okay did you speak to him after he was
in the Oval Office with Kanye then I
guess you hadn't see if you have no
evidence what did you think of that
Kareem was kind of bizarre you know I'm
sure that you probably wanted to get out
of there when Kanye was doing his little
accent you know
and I'm just seeing a photograph here
with you Muhammad Ali and and Bill
Russell shades of yesteryear Jim Brown
what was that what was the circumstances
around this photograph that was the
Cleveland summit that was the attempt by
Jim Brown and Bill Russell to get a
number of athletes together to see if we
could help Muhammad Ali deal with the
issues he had with the federal
government over refusing to go to
Vietnam so we wanted to talk to Ali and
and find out where his head was and see
if we could could help him deal with it
in a way where they didn't come down on
him so hard but you know within 10 or 15
minutes we realized that he was totally
comfortable with what he was doing and
he he didn't care if they you know
censured him the way they did he had a
point to make and he made it what do you
think Ali would have thought of what's
going on with Kaepernick right now
Kareem I'm sure Ali would have
understood what Kaepernick is doing and
been 100% supportive of them Kareem
abdul-jabbar here on the Rich Eisen show
okay let's get to the October legends
Kareem abdul-jabbar collection featuring
a hundred and forty-six lots of your
memorabilia that is going to be
available right now golden auctions ggod
gol di and auctions.com now through
October 27th and I have a couple of
items right here a few trinkets this is
I'm holding in my hand game used from
the 8687 season and you autographed the
Lakers home jersey with shorts yes right
here you have a number of those a couple
of those all right now here's another
one I'm holding up right here game-used
Lakers Jersey from 1986 so you would say
you saved these and you just been
sitting around in your garage and your
and my mom had a lot of stuff because my
yeah my mom lived in Queens right
and when I'd win things from the NBA
they'd send it to my mom's house in
Queens I told him to do that so my mom
had a whole treasure trove in the
basement their rings and uniforms and
there
when you set a record or you had
something they said just send it to your
mom's place in Queens right so and then
my mom moved out to Los Angeles in 85
she and my dad and I inherited all this
stuff and it was a lot of stuff and so
now you want to I want to use it in the
right way the significant proportion of
the proceeds will go for my for my camp
where I sent I send kids from the LA
Unified School District so that they can
learn about STEM subjects mm-hmm it's
it's been a really good program we have
like the four or five year waiting list
and we need money for buses and to pay
the teachers and you know all the people
that help us do this and this is amazing
Rock when you have no idea ago I'll send
it over to you in a second that's just
seeing it up it looks our side of the
and these are two of these championship
rings and imposing championship rings as
my UCLA ring is about 3nc Toit
championships and then that other one
you have there I think that's 1982 why
do you want to sell these thing mlu for
they have lots of sentimental value okay
but I I don't have 12 fingers and
fingers that is great okay yeah if they
had 12 fingers you'd be able to wear
them all this is amazing so again golden
auctions.com
yeah for that and for all people you
know they want to have a piece of my
history they can they can come and bid
the the auction star stops October 27th
yep okay and then Mycroft and Sherlock
is your latest home
yes it's I've written about the
backstory of Mycroft Holmes he's
Sherlock's older and smarter brother and
I tried to talk about his backstory you
know the in Arthur Conan Doyle's Canon
of work and he's only mentioned a couple
of times about five or six times and yes
have no idea of who he is or why he is
who he is
so I
decided to backtrack a couple of years
and talk about Mycroft and it's done
very well when did you first get into
Sherlock Holmes and Mycroft Holmes was a
kid when I was a kid I used to watch the
series from England with the Basil
Rathbone
sure they used to show it on Saturdays
Sherlock Holmes theatre with the hash
yeah we were headin right and then more
recently but what happened was it my
second year in high school we've read
Arthur Conan Doyle and that that's the
first time I realized that he wasn't
that Sherlock Holmes was not actually a
real person and up to that point I
thought he actually was the real person
a lot of people do in fact even today
Sherlock Holmes still gets mail from
around the world sent to his address in
London at Baker Street and thank ya 221
Baker Street they have a museum there
sure
Wow and so do you like the BBC series
though oh the BBC series is great
because it really shows what Sherlock
would be like in the 21st century and
III think that's great and Elementary is
pretty good too yeah yeah that's another
one absolutely another one before I let
you go I do have to ask you a couple of
pop culture questions if you don't know
course okay how did you get involved
with airplane the movie airplane um
the sucker brothers are from Wisconsin
and they had wanted Pete Rose to play
the role that I played but they shot
they shot the movie during the summer
and Pete was playing so since they were
the circle brothers are from Whitefish
Bay Wisconsin and they said maybe cream
will do it and they got in touch with me
I said yeah I'll do it
you do it yeah did you come up with the
names of Walton and Lanier no no that
was the writers yeah okay yeah and where
is the Jersey that you warned that
dragged up the aisle because that could
bid on that I would bid on that Jersey
for sure I have no idea that's it yeah
we should find that one I would look
that one out huh and so what was that I
like on the set it was so much fun you
know Chris it's kind of hard to believe
I'm going to work every morning and I'm
sitting next to Peter Graves you know I
used to watch Mission Impossible
Here I am sitting next to him every
morning you know good morning and stuff
it's crazy but it was fun a lot of fun
doing it Leslie Nielsen was out of his
mind
you know what do you mean he was out of
his mind he's crazy man he had a he had
this little can that if he manipulated
it sounded like flatulence right
she had a whoopee cushion right so he
come up to you and start talking to you
and then start working the can and the
people would be like what what's going
on and if you didn't know he'd take it
he'd mess with your head yeah Leslie was
crazy man man that's that's just an
all-time great I've every time I see it
it still makes me laugh and then how did
you meet Bruce Lee how did you meet him
I met Bruce Lee when I was starting my
junior year at UCLA and I started
studying martial arts Nana formally and
I wanted to continue doing that so I
asked a friend over at the black belt
magazine you know who I could study with
and he said maybe you might want to
study with Bruce Danny Knights what a
suggestion
yeah he just referred me over to my
Bruce I called him he said Nia come on
over to the house Hank went over to his
house and mmm we talked about it and had
a great way of convincing me because
he'd want to know if I could punch him
kick right so he got behind the bag the
heavy bag and had me punch and kick it
said okay hmm
so I thought he was gonna show me how he
punched in King but instead he had his
wife come out his wife his wife Elena
who's weighs maybe 120 hundred 25 pounds
and he had me braced myself against the
heavy bag and she kicked it and the
force that she put through the bag
knocked my body away from it and I said
I want to know how to do that and that
was that I started studying with him and
we were from friends from that time
until he passed away until he passed
away what was the height difference
between you and him and Bruce Lee do you
think Oh foot and a half I mean just
we're looking at the footage of this
yeah you know and wearing the shades was
that your idea whose idea was made me
look villainous I'm the bad guy I have
to
uh-huh so they made me look mysterious
and villainous yes as you're knocking
him to the floor with my dirty feet and
what do you think of when you see this
stuff well it makes me remember Bruce
you know I that's the last time I saw
him was when we did this film so it
really it's a nostalgic in a way that
you know I I get kind of misty because
he was such a good guy he's a good
friend of yours right he was a good guy
and just you know I used to babysit for
his son and you know Oh like we had a
whole lot of history kareem abdul-jabbar
here on the Rich Eisen show are you
going to the first game of the bran or
of course yeah I'll be there the Lakers
know how to put on a show don't they I
mean they really know how to put did
what do you think Jerry Buss would think
of LeBron come in here oh he be ecstatic
I mean he lucked up getting magic and
now you know having the good fortune to
sign the bran and have LeBron come and
bring all of that that he brings is it's
it's great it's great for the city and
it's great for the Lakers well great
Kareem thanks for coming on here you are
welcome here anytime I always enjoy our
chats thank you so much please keep
writing books if that's uh if that's
what you want to keep doing and prim to
come on this show to promote it I'm all
here for that Mycroft and Sherlock
Kareem abdul-jabbar his latest book
right there golden auctions the October
legends Kareem abdul-jabbar collection I
have championship rings right here I've
got signed jerseys and shorts right over
there go to golden auctions.com right
now through October 27th and go to
becoming Kareem calm for tour dates and
more info to see Kareem live good to see
did I get it all down you got it all
thank you so much you bet Kareem
abdul-jabbar right kaj 33 on twitter
that's what's going down here your phone
calls at 8 for 4 204 rich number to dial
here on this edition of the Rich Eisen
show when we come back the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience